>> AMBASSADOR, WELCOME TO THE
PROGRAM.
>> THANK YOU.
I AM DELIGHTED TO BE HERE.
>> SO WE ARE HERE IN THE HEART
OF THE MATTER.
THIS IS A GRAIN MILLING
PROCESSOR HERE.
IT'S A VITAL PART OF THIS
COUNTRY'S EXPORT.
IT'S VITAL FOR PEOPLES FOOD
SUPPLY AROUND THE WORLD.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT IT WILL --
THE DEAL WILL BE RENEWED MID
NOVEMBER, AND WHAT DO YOU MAKE
OF PUTIN THAT HE CAME BACK INTO
THE DEAL AFTER THREATENING TO
EXIT IT?
>> WELL, I'M HOPING THAT THE
DEAL WILL BE EXTENDED.
I KNOW THAT EXTRAORDINARY
EFFORTS ARE BEING MADE BY THE
SECRETARY GENERAL AND OTHERS TO
NEGOTIATE AN EXTENSION OF THIS
DEAL.
THE FACT THAT PUTIN PULLED OUT
THE DEAL TEMPORARILY SHOWS THAT
HE HAS NO CONCERN ABOUT THE
IMPACT THAT THIS IS HAVING
AROUND THE WORLD.
HE SENT SHOCKS AROUND THE WORLD
WHEN HE DID THIS.
HE GOT TREMENDOUS PRESSURE FROM
EVERYONE AND CAME BACK.
HE HAD NO CHOICE BUT TO COME
BACK INTO THE DEAL.
AGAIN, I THINK IT SHOWS THAT HE
REALLY DOES NOT CARE ABOUT THE
PEOPLE HIS UNPROVOKED WAR IS
IMPACTING.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE RARE
AREAS OF COOPERATION IN THIS
VICIOUS WAR.
ALSO PRISONER EXCHANGES IS A
RARE AREA OF COOPERATION.
PEOPLE DON'T FOCUS ON THAT SO
MUCH PERHAPS.
DOES THAT GIVE YOU ANY HOPE OR
GROUNDS FOR INABILITY TO
DISCUSS WITH THEM WHEN YOU ARE
IN THE SECURITY COUNCIL ON THE
BIGGER ISSUE?
>> I THINK WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN
THE SECURITY COUNCIL BY THE
RUSSIANS IS A TOTAL LACK OF
SENSITIVITY.
A TOTAL LACK OF COOPERATION.
THEY HAVE USED THE SECURITY
COUNCIL TO PUSH FORWARD THEIR
NEGATIVE AND THEIR NARRATIVE.
THERE MISINFORMATION.
THEIR ATTACKS ON THE PEOPLE OF
UKRAINE.
WE HAVE USED THE COUNCIL TO
ISOLATE THEM AND CONDEMN THEM.
WE'VE ALSO TAKEN IT TO THE
GENERAL ASSEMBLY WHERE THEY
HAVE BEEN ROUNDLY CONDEMNED.
SO I DON'T SEE THE RUSSIANS AT
THIS POINT LOOKING TO USE THE
SECURITY COUNCIL AS A FORM
WHERE THEY WILL COOPERATE WITH
THE REST OF THE WORLD.
>> DOES IT BOTHER YOU THAT NOT
JUST THE WIND, BUT NATIONAL
GOVERNMENTS LIKE YOURS AND
OTHERS, HAVE PUT A HUGE NUMBER
OF SANCTIONS ON RUSSIA FOR ALL
THAT IT'S DOING HERE?
>> DOES IT BOTHER ME?
>> NO, THE FACT THAT RUSSIA IS
STILL DOING WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
DOES THAT BOTHER YOU?
THAT IT'S CHANGED ITS MARKET.
IT'S ACTUALLY SELLING ENERGY.
THAT ITS NARRATIVE IN THE
DEVELOPING WORLD SEEMS TO BE
WINNING.
>> I DON'T THINK THEY ARE DOING
WELL.
I THINK THE SANCTIONS ARE
HAVING AN IMPACT ON THEM.
I SEE A SENSE OF DESPERATION ON
THEIR PART.
THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE TO HAVE
THIS DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN
AROUND THE WORLD SHOWS THAT
THIS IS --
THEY ARE DESPERATE, THAT THIS
IS HAVING AN IMPACT ON THEM,
AND I THINK THE REST OF THE
WORLD IS SEEING THROUGH THEIR
FALSE NARRATIVE.
>> YOU ARE ALSO VISITING A
FORENSIC LABORATORY TODAY
REGARDING WAR CRIMES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOU THINK
AND WHERE YOU THINK THAT IS.
PLUS, I SPOKE TO TWO SENIOR
SENATORS WHO ARE ON A VISIT
JUST LAST WEEK ACTUALLY SAID
THAT THEY WANTED TO TAKE TO THE
ICC, WHICH IS THE UN MANDATED
WAR CRIMES TRIBUNAL, THE IDEA
OF A SEPARATE SPECIAL TRIBUNAL
FOR UKRAINE.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT THE U.S.
SUPPORTS?
THAT THE UN SUPPORTS?
>> RIGHT NOW, I'M HERE TO SEE
THE EFFORTS TO DOCUMENT
EVIDENCE OF WAR CRIMES.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF ENTITIES,
THE ICC, THE I-C.J., OTHER
ENTITIES WITH INVESTIGATIONS
TAKING PLACE WITHIN THE UN,
INCLUDING THE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HERE.
THE PROSECUTORS OFFICE HERE,
WHO ARE ALL INVESTIGATING WAR
CRIMES AND GATHERING THE DATA.
SO WE ARE LOOKING AT ENSURING
THAT WE SUPPORT THEIR EFFORTS
TO GATHER THE DATA, SO THAT
WHEN IT GOES BEFORE WHATEVER
INVESTIGATION OR TRIBUNAL, THAT
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE THE EVIDENCE
IN HAND TO PROSECUTE.
>> YOU KNOW, I WAS AROUND FOR
THE SPECIAL TRIBUNAL FOR BOSNIA,
YUGOSLAVIA, AND RWANDA.
DO YOU THINK A SPECIAL TRIBUNAL
IS NEEDED?
OR, AS THE ICC HAS SAID, WE
HAVE WHAT IT TAKES, WE HAVE THE
PROSECUTOR, THE PEOPLE, THE
RESOURCES.
>> AT THIS MOMENT, I THINK THE
RESOURCES ARE THERE BUT AS WE
GET INTO MORE OF THE
DOCUMENTATION, THOSE
DETERMINATIONS CAN BE MADE
LATER.
BUT RIGHT NOW THERE ARE
ORGANIZATIONS AND INSTITUTIONS,
THE ICC CAN DO, IT THE ICJ CAN
DO IT, THE PROCESS --
PROSECUTORS OFFICE OF UKRAINE,
THEY ARE ALL AVAILABLE TO DO
THE PROSECUTIONS NECESSARY.
I HEARD TODAY THERE'S MORE THAN
60,000 CASES CAN THAT HAVE BEEN
PUT FORWARD.
THERE MAY BE MANY MANY MORE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS IS
GOING TO LEAD.
TO >> AMBASSADOR, WE ARE
SITTING HERE RIGHT ON THE DAY
OF THE MIDTERMS IN YOUR
COUNTRY.
I WON'T ASK YOU TO WEIGH IN
POLITICALLY, BUT AS YOU KNOW
THERE'S SOME SUGGESTION THAT
THERE MIGHT BE UKRAINE FATIGUE
GIVEN THE ENERGY COST, GIVEN
THE PAIN FOR EVERY COUNTRY'S
CITIZENRY.
EUROPE IS HAVING A VERY HARD
TIME.
DO YOU BELIEVE THIS COULD CHIP
AWAY AT THE UNITED FRONT FOR
CONTINUED SANCTIONS AGAINST
RUSSIA?
COULD CHIP AWAY AT THE SUPPORT
FOR UKRAINE AROUND THE WORLD?
>> CHRISTIANE, WE HAVE BEEN
UNIFIED FROM DAY ONE AND WE
HAVE NOT SEEN ANY CRACKS IN
THAT UNITY.
EUROPE IS UNIFIED.
NATO IS UNIFIED.
WE'VE HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE UNITED STATES FOR SUPPORT
FOR UKRAINE.
OUR SUPPORT IS UNWAVERING AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO BE UNIFIED.
UNTIL UKRAINE WINS THIS WAR AND
RUSSIA TAKES THEIR TROOPS OUT
OF UKRAINE.
>> SO, WE ARE IN A GRAIN
PROCESSING SILO.
[NOISE] --
>> IT'S OKAY.
ON THAT LEVEL, WE UNDERSTAND
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER JAKE
SULLIVAN WAS HERE A FEW DAYS
AGO.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE UNITED
STATES IS TRYING TO PERSUADE
THE PRESIDENT, YOU ARE GOING TO
VISIT, PRESIDENT SMOLENSKI, TO
LEAST SOUND WILLING FOR SOME
KIND OF NEGOTIATION WITH
RUSSIA.
DO YOU BELIEVE RIGHT NOW THAT
THE UNITED STATES SHOULD BE
PUSHING NEGOTIATIONS?
I KNOW THE U.S. SAYS WE ARE
WITH UKRAINE, NOT WITHOUT
UKRAINE.
BUT DO YOU BELIEVE THAT MOMENT
HAS COME TO TRY AND GET ALL
PARTIES AROUND A NEGOTIATION
TABLE?
>> LOOK, AT THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY WANTS JUSTICE FOR THE
PEOPLE OF UKRAINE.
AND ANY NEGOTIATIONS THAT TAKE
PLACE HAVE TO TAKE PLACE WITH
UKRAINE IN THE DRIVER SEAT.
WHEN THEY ARE READY FOR THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE BACKING
AND SUPPORT OF THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY,
FOLLOWING THE CHARTER THAT
RUSSIA HAS VIOLATED, THAT IS
WHERE WE ARE ON THESE
NEGOTIATIONS.
UKRAINE IS FIGHTING FOR ITS
LIFE.
OUR SUPPORT FOR THEM WILL
CONTINUE TO BE STRONG AND
CONTINUE TO BE UNWAVERING.
>> SO THE U.S. AND PERMANENT
FIVE WHO ACTUALLY SUPPORT YOU
ARE NOT PUSHING THEM TO THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE?
>> WE HAVE BEEN CLEAR, NO
NEGOTIATIONS IN WHICH UKRAINE
IS NOT IN THE DRIVER SEAT.
NO NEGOTIATIONS ABOUT UKRAINE
WITHOUT UKRAINE.
>> IRAN.
THE IDEA OF THE SHOW HEAT
KAMIKAZE DRONES, POTENTIAL
BALLISTIC MISSILES, POTENTIALLY
IRAN ASKING RUSSIA FOR HELP
WITH ITS NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
IRAN HAS ALSO BEEN SANCTIONED
TO WITHIN AN INCH OF ITS LIFE.
HOW DO YOU BRING IRAN INTO SOME
KIND OF COMPLIANCE OR NOT?
>> LOOK, IRAN PROVIDING DRONES
TO RUSSIA'S SECURITY COUNCIL
VIOLATION.
RUSSIA RECEIVING THOSE DRONES
HAS BROKEN A SECURITY COUNCIL
RESOLUTIONS.
AND SO WE ARE LOOKING AT
BRINGING THIS BEFORE THE
COUNCIL TO DISCUSS IN THE
COUNCIL, AND WE HAVE ASKED THE
SECRETARY GENERAL UNDER
RESOLUTION 22.31, TO
INVESTIGATE WHAT IRAN IS
CURRENTLY DOING WITH RUSSIA.
THEY ARE PROVIDING DRONES THAT
ARE ATTACKING CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE.
>> DO YOU BUY THEIR VERSION OF
IT?
THE FOREIGN MINISTER SAID WE
SOLD IT AS PART OF A DEFENSE
DEAL BEFORE THE WAR?
>> WE HAVE SEEN EVIDENCE OF
THOSE DRONES BEING PROVIDED
SINCE THE WAR STARTED.
THEY KNOW THAT, THE RUSSIANS
KNOW THAT, AND WE DO.
>> AND ON THE WOMEN'S MOVEMENT
THERE, EUROPE IS LOOKING TO
SANCTION ALL OF THOSE
PARLIAMENTARIANS WHO HAVE
SUGGESTED HARSH PROSECUTION FOR
WOMEN PROTESTERS.
WHAT WILL THE SECURITY COUNCIL
DO IF ANYTHING?
>> WELL, YOU MAY KNOW THAT LAST
WEEK WITH THE ALBANIAN'S WE
HOSTED A DISCUSSION ABOUT IRAN,
AND WE BROUGHT THE SECURITY
COUNCIL, AND A NUMBER OF MEMBER
STATES INTO THE ROOM TO REALLY
DISCUSS WHAT IS HAPPENING THERE,
TO DISCUSS WHERE SUPPORT FOR
THE IRANIAN WOMEN.
TO SHOW OUR CONDEMNATION OF
IRAN.
I THINK THE IRANIANS HEARD IT
LOUD AND CLEAR, BECAUSE WE
STARTED HEARING FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES THAT THEY WERE
REACHING OUT TO DISCOURAGE THEM
FROM PARTICIPATING IN THIS
MEETING, AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO RAISE THIS IN NEW YORK AND
THE COUNCIL AND ELSEWHERE IN
THE HUMAN RIGHTS COUNCIL UNTIL
IRAN STOPPED THEIR BRUTAL
ATTACK ON WOMEN IN IRAN.
>> WHICH PRETTY MUCH PUTS A
NUCLEAR DEAL OFF THE TABLE?
>> RIGHT NOW, WE ARE FOCUSED ON
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IN TERMS OF
ATTACKING WOMEN AND WHAT THEY
ARE DOING IN TERMS OF PROVIDING
WHEREWITHAL FOR RUSSIA TO
ATTACK CIVILIAN INFRASTRUCTURE
HERE IN UKRAINE.
>> AMBASSADOR, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH INDEED.
>> THANK YOU.